son imágenes de una cámara de seguridad
en Irán un hombre persigue a un
paramilitar del grupo basic vinculado a
la guardia Revolucionaria iraní y al
frente de la represión el asaltante lo
apuñala después hace lo mismo con un
segundo que le intenta detener este
hombre supuestamente era magitte
y ha sido la segunda persona ejecutada
en Irán por participar en las protestas
así habló en su juicio unos días antes
la razón de mi odio contra los basitis y
las fuerzas de seguridad fueron los
videos publicados en las redes sociales
que los mostraban golpeando y matando
gente vi los videos y creí que eso era
verdad
este anuncio ha reavivado la ira de los
manifestantes contra la teocracia iraní
según amnistía internacional ya hay una
veintena de condenados a muerte
el jueves fue ejecutado y de 23 años le
acusaban de bloquear una calle y herida
un paramilitar tras el anuncio la
comunidad internacional protestó y
sancionó las autoridades iraníes se
defienden y han estado acusando de
injerencia a Estados Unidos e Israel
organizaciones defensoras de los
Derechos Humanos sitúan en cerca de 500
los manifestantes muertos la ONU asegura
que son más de 300 Mientras que el
gobierno anunció más de 200 son las
consecuencias de las mayores protestas
en décadas en Irán después de la muerte
en custodia policial de masa mini por no
llevar